[Musik]
triberg im schwarzwald ein idealer
ausgangspunkt um im wald zu wandern und
die schöne natur zu genießen
besonders eindrucksvoll eine der
weltgrößten kuckucksuhren wer lust auf
süßes hat ist im café adler gut
aufgehoben
hier gibt es feinste confiserie und
unter den vielen kuchen auch die königin
des schwarzwaldes die schwarzwälder
kirschtorte für konditormeisterin
bergmann holzer im sortiment und
verzichtbar
vier personen oder eine familie
amüsierten bestelle drei fahrzeuge und
einer was andere von ihm er ist es sehr
bedeutend uns für den biskuit boden
benötigt man 180 gramm mehl rund 80
gramm speisestärke 40 gramm kakaopulver
etwas sammer eine familie und einen
spritzer zitronensaft außerdem fünf eier
wie getrennt werden
das schaumig geschlagene eiweiß süß die
konditoren mit 200 gramm zu
dann heben sie das verkehrte eigelb und
dass anschließend die mail kaum mischung
dazu
[Musik]
alle gut verloren
natürlich die vorgefertigte schöner die
masse in unseren ringfinger
dann war das unser es geboren in den
ofen bei 180 grad ca 20 minuten für die
kirsch füllung werden eingemachte
sauerkirschen mit kirschsaft zucker und
stärke aufgetaucht wie im fertigen
besprüht boden schneidet dagmar holzer
in eine dicke und zweiten beschreiben
dann gebe ich jetzt die sauerkirschen in
die mitte des bodens und verteilen sie
vorsichtig mit der palette in die steif
geschlagene sahne kommt ein gutes
schnapsglas hochprozentiges kirschwasser
diese sicht kommt direkt auf die
kirschen und wird gleichmäßig bis zum
rand des kuchens verteilt
so umgehen wir den ersten boden dazu zu
dienen leicht an
auch der bogen wird gut mit kirschwasser
getränkt denn für sagte holzer ist der
alkoholgeschmack wichtig
[Musik]
über die nächste seine decke kommt der
dritte und letzte boden
jetzt können die formen abgenommen
werden der gesamte kuchen wird nun auch
an den seiten mit sahne bestrichen und
mit rosetten und schokoraspeln verziert
[Musik]
bitterschokolade gebe ich jetzt oben in
der miete drauf so dass man jetzt fast
fertig und wurde vom nachttisch letzte
etablieren
die allerletzte vergleich obendrauf
[Musik]
auch wenn die schwarzwälder kirschtorte
als kalorienbombe geht so gehört sie für
viele zu einem ausflug in den
schwarzwald einfach dazu
[Musik]